a Nintendo 64 handheld and the e-elt is
a new telescope that not only will be
the biggest in the world but it's
nicknamed the Alien Hunter Vsauce Kevin
here this is my flow
researchers at Dallas use the Mirage
effect to create a kind of invisibility
cloak
the highly conductive carbon nanotubes
are pressed into a transparent sheet and
submerged in water when the switches
flip they quickly heat the water around
it causing the Mirage effect which bends
the light towards the viewers eyes and
conceals the object on the other side to
conceal your face just wear one of these
super realistic 3d face replicas a
Japanese company is creating these human
face copies by imprinting pictures of a
person's face taken from various
positions on vinyl chloride resin
stretched over a mold get one for about
four thousand dollars for an anime
inspired robotic head a San Francisco
company built this mecha bond the head
was created with 3d printer painted and
the glowing emotive ears were actually
inspired by puppy ears
the throwable panoramic camera is a
concept that allows the user to take a
360 degree panorama by in the air
it's equipped with 36 cell phone camera
sensors and it takes the picture when
the ball reaches a brief stationary
moment at the height of the toss now
let's watch the cube storm or to solve a
rubik's cube faster than the human world
record it uses four Lego Mindstorms NXT
kits and a samsung galaxy s2 with a
custom program and it's done after 25
years of study scientists believe humans
and almost all vertebrae descended from
a common ancestor with a sixth sense
that allowed it to detect electrical
fields thanks to its electroreceptive
organs but we lost that sense somewhere
along the way so yeah instead we do
things like base jump off hotels in
Spain like these guys
or build motorized toilets like these
guys they like to add motors to random
things including this couch which
successfully went over 101 miles per
hour breaking the world record for
fastest couch okay look at the size of
these two cigarettes got it and yeah
they're the same size
finally claymation musicals and pac-man
combined in this short from the folks
and random encounters decide to peck the
fries in ketchup X oh my fitness pac-man
smile at the time guess I'll be going
there my digestive tract I'm gonna leave
you with 3d comics there are four clues
in the description of this video the
first person to answer all four
correctly will be our genius of the week
so good luck and as always thanks for
watching